[Applaudissements]
qui sont tournées dans toute la france
en 2020 mais chéri et à l'olympia le 17
et 18 juillet bien dedans touche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
messieurs ce soir c'est une émission de
ouf dans un instant on recevra marc
antoine le bret
l'arpp antoine le bret qui va nous
parler de son nouveau spectacle jeu-là
d'or c'est mon préféré soit un autre
ancien chroniqueur de l'émission pierre
menez qui est avec total on me dit dans
l'oreillette que c'est bernard me d'être
déchiré chaude ou dans un instant ont
rappelé la grand-mère de caris on lui
dira que booba et mabiala ken mais
d'abord j'ai présenté les chroniqueurs
mes chroniqueurs je vous le dis c'est
pas les meilleurs mais ils sont pas
chères
je rencontre et j'ai même perdu des
fiches s'il reste sans bouger au bord de
la route
on peut le prendre pour un feu orange
bernanke belle intelligente et elle aime
l'archéologie vous lâche de son coeur
delphine c'est moi j'ai barack obama sur
la ligne mais le gars il a une top à la
place du cerveau
la preuve il a eu tellement d'érection à
l'intérieur du crâne que ces veuves sont
tombés gens méchants
la dernière fois qu'il a fait chaud il
meurt on payait encore en francs maxime
colin
une fois le meilleur des meilleurs le
plus talentueux des chroniqueurs mais
comme il était pas dispo j'ai pris le
premier venu gilles de l'accord
c'est mon préféré elle est pleine de
culture comme une bibliothèque
elle est belle comme une bibliothèque et
aucun de nous est entré dans une
bibliothèque c'est ma préférée
il a réussi en télévision sans avoir
besoin de coucher à bien il ya une
erreur vivement sur la touche à grasse
je présente un match au delà est la
deuxième personne la plus à gauche la
plus amoureuse de match de hambourg
après matthieu delormeau lui-même
francesca les sondés connais le gars à
la base est venu ici pour livrer des
boissons garder parce qu'il a une grande
gueule et que la demande pas beaucoup
d'argent on vraiment
[Applaudissements]
l'algérie voilà elle ne touche pas à
l'édito elle ne touche pas aux platines
et pourtant elle arrive à toucher un
salaire
kelly la série sont le maquereau de la
merguez sur le tajine le loukoum sur la
canebière
si vous en pensez jean claude van damme
bonjour envoie enchanté on se parle plus
tard et bientôt le bal des campings au
pouvoir faire des chants bretons faisons
le bricolage nolwenn leroy merlin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'hier en voiture je suis passé
un fonds en marche arrière devant un
radar pas de ckoi j'ai récupéré six
points de permis direct j'aimerais bien
qu'on ait des nouvelles de jean lassalle
aussi dans un autre je m'en sers solaire
quand j'ai vu bonjour bonjour monsieur
je tousse et jaune dans les rangs points
je me suis dit ça y est c'est un appel
aux gens
[Applaudissements]
c'est marc antoine tu vas leur seigneur
tu vas essayer 15 limitation en une
minute safran gros 6 secondes pour faire
une voix et une vanne sur la personne
fait qu'il faut une voix et une vanne je
te donne je donne à chaque fois les
personnes
ok tu me dit compter près allez c'est
parti à tokyo bon il bacio bas les
hommes c'est comme des poissons rouges
et dirige principalement avec leur coeur
ils ont mis tout de ce combat ok chose
mumba nombreuses au maire de carros et
arielle dombasle
bonjour c'est arielle dombasle à toutes
les personnes présentes bonsoir tous les
hommes et bonsoir à tous les hommes et à
tous et de toutes les femmes vers saint
françois cusey solo c'est françois cusin
bon je suis super contente l'om didier
deschamps
mon genre moi et mes dents de lait nous
sommes contents d'être athée jean marie
bigard c'est vrai que attention tu étais
une question de vocabulaire comme dans
la phrase la petite elle encore pris 15
cm cet été ben c'est pas pareil si c'est
vrai qu'il a dit ou 6,6 me louis boré
candeloro il fait sinon agir contre le
réchauffement climatique n'est ce pas
mon cher philippe candeloro tu m'étonnes
elson avec il ya deux trois bonnes à son
public et donne envie d'agir
d'accord réchauffement climatique dans
mon slip à la tire de le mot que
j'utilise comme je vous laisse je vais
la muscu gilles verdez m'attend mais
c'est en tord à bernard de la
villardière en temps réel charisme tout
truc sauta là dessous
alors j'ai traîné chez eux dans télé 3d
emmanuel macron de perdre on va vous
dire mais les décisions c'est comme les
femmes j'aime quand elles ont mûri très
longtemps et je vous dis ça je vous dis
tout ça sans carabistouilles moque on
fait plein de sens que si elle ça
m'occupe arles c'est moi qui parle mais
classé mots qui parlent c'est moi à ces
mots qui parlent au québec alors je te
kiffe alors françois damiens pour finir
au lieu d'un flagrant manque aussi rien
et comme vous aussi vous êtes cool ça
fait une sacrée paire 2 cuil
[Applaudissements]